[Music]
[Music]
hey you guys
what's going on yeah talking about a
great movie today
oh my god it's a can i just say if you
guys can't see the chat
um i laughed out loud when i saw what tb
triggers put
they put hey guys it seems to me beneath
this waiting screen
there's something wonderful just waiting
to get out yeah which is
a reference to boogie nights i laughed
very very hard when i saw that so that's
it thank you very much for that
really good movie i think it starts off
supposed to be like with 77
it does start in 1977 yeah california
uh southern california area you know i
was about eight years old this time
and uh the porn industry and it's
loosely based on what
some of the stuff that really happened
in the porn industry like john holmes
it's called boogie nights they look
changed all the names protect the
innocent i love
this movie good yeah so much it's aged
very well
what year did this come out 97 97 it's
aged very well you know what's funny
i saw this movie it's directed by paul
thomas anderson
and uh who made this when he was 26
[ __ ] years old i can't
he had made actually he made a short
film when he was 17
that was kind of like a mockumentary
that was sort of based on john holmes
but it was called the dark digler story
and um that this is like his
feature-length version of that so he's
been had been kicking around this idea
for a long time
i saw this in the theater in 1997 and i
[ __ ] loved it
yeah and i distinctly remember going to
the bathroom afterward and there was
this old lady
in she was at the sink next to me and
she looks to me and she goes
did you know that movie was going to be
like that
i guess she didn't know it was about
porn it was an old lady and i was like
do you guys like not read the plot
synopsis
like before you go see a movie no people
will see a random movie
they don't have anything better yeah
yeah she was like
well i don't know i just thought that
was i remember watching uh prometheus
there was an old couple in front of me
when that [ __ ] was over the dude goes
what was that about
okay yeah this uh really this is
uh i i would say the highlight of this
movie
in terms of just like this this movie is
a monument
to um burt reynolds this is
this is his best movie he got an oscar
nomination oh he did yeah
i'm telling you i don't know if he i
don't think he won but he got an oscar
nomination yeah reynolds knocks it out
of the [ __ ] park he's
so good at this yeah really really good
in it
um everybody in it is really good mark
wahlberg is really good in it just
everybody is good in this movie nina
hartley has a [ __ ] uh
uh cameo in it yeah she is she's old
school [ __ ]
porn star um it's just just a good move
it's a good story about
friends in a scene and how [ __ ] they
kind of came from nothing and
made a living for themselves and how
they were kind of dumb but that's the
way it is
you know and then it kind of turns dark
for a while but then they kind of take
care of each other and some of the
people that you know
turns out were you know involved in some
bad [ __ ] with little kids and [ __ ] and
they got locked up for it and what
happened to that dude he got beat up in
jail
been beat up in prison just it's kind of
like a standard
rise fall redemption yeah uh story
and i've seen a couple um there's some
really good
uh videos like analyzing this movie and
in particular comparing it to
goodfellas which you wouldn't really
think about
it like that it is a lot like goodfellas
very similar tone
yeah so i mean paul thomas anderson is a
big fan of barnes scorsese so you could
see like he was making some homages to
it like in the
in the movie it's the good fellows of
the porn world yeah
yeah because it's like it's something
that's you know it was porn was legal
but there was like other illegal [ __ ]
going on too so it's almost kind of like
has a little bit of a
um you know a parallel to the gangster
world yeah porn was going on but there
was a lot of illegal drugs
there is uh um just uh
people losing custody of their children
and you know all the ramifications of
being a porn star
like you couldn't really borrow any
money from the bank and because they
thought you would just
[ __ ] make porn make more porn
[Laughter]
kind of funny you know a good story real
good story
i mean this is just it's it's a great
ensemble piece
also i think something else that i saw
pointed out that was again kind of
similar to goodfellas was that the theme
of this
was despite all the porn and all the
drugs and shenanigans
the theme was people finding a family
you know what i mean because it was
almost kind of like i mean dirk digler
nominally the main character
yeah um coming from a really terrible
household
like his mom is just this drunk that
just tells him how stupid he is all the
time
his dad is just kind of like over it and
it's just like i'm not even getting
involved anymore yeah his dad's kind of
like giving up
yeah he said well you know i kind of
[ __ ] detected that there was
something going on
with the mom the mom was [ __ ] kind of
jealous of the son
in certain ways well she was a drunk too
dating girls and [ __ ] it was just some
weird [ __ ]
going on there it might have been i mean
you know they didn't really this doesn't
really hit on it
but was there some kind of because yeah
maybe
well because i mean the you know dirk
diggler who's you know
his real name is eddie in the movie is
eddie adams but um
since he's so cock-centric i mean that's
his one special thing
that's the only thing it's his big huge
dick yeah um maybe
yeah maybe the mom wants to jump on it
yeah or maybe was
or maybe he was jumping on that and now
he's like you know now he's grown and
he's like not taking it anymore
right but i mean it's so all of these
people and i think it's implied too
that roller girl uh played by heather
graham i know they don't really show her
home life but it is kind of they show
her in school like in high school and
how everybody's like kind of picking on
her because i guess everybody's sort of
well some of them knew that they were
born yeah someone knew that she was in
porn that sound you know what that
sounds like though that's kind of like a
ripoff of um
the girl that ended up being later on
and uh cry baby
yeah yeah yeah that's her name man
that's just went right out of my head
cry baby
tracy laura tracy
but tracy lords wasn't around the 70s
that was 80s
yeah maybe very late 70s but that's
probably what they're talking about all
the characters in this are fantastic
and i love the way i mean it's almost
kind of like so the first part of it is
almost like
funny because like i said it's sort of
like it's a comedy drama
i guess if you want to put it like that
and
the first half of it which is kind of
like dirk's rise to fame
and him getting everything that he wants
almost like a fairy tale type of thing
and everything is going well
but even though everything's going well
and it's like a big party and [ __ ]
there's still like little clues kind of
threaded throughout
that shit's gonna like crash and burn
later on
you know what i mean there's the whole
there's like really subtle [ __ ] like
um you know the one where uh amber waves
played by julianne moore like where she
gets that phone call at the party
and uh you know it's her kid calling and
she misses it because nobody knows what
her real name is
um you know that that really little
skinny girl like
uh oding at the party and everyone being
kind of
i love that when they said they show up
at the party the first thing she has you
got any coke at this party yeah
and they got one of the guy who's in the
crew i think he does lighting or
something had to do with the on the film
crew yeah and uh
his wife keeps showing up to all the
damn parties
she's not a porn star but she's screwing
all the people screwing them all in
public and [ __ ]
in front of him and he every time he's
turning around he's finding his [ __ ]
wife
in front of everybody in the park you
know that shit's gonna go bad
that ends up going bad well i feel like
because the
the cool thing i like the transition
between everything being awesome and
like a big party which it kind of was
like in the 70s
and then it culminating at that new
year's party where
it's 1980 now yeah and it's
new year taken over yeah there's all
these changes in the air like videos
taking over like amateur porn stars like
more that kind of thing like it was more
cheaply produced
and um you know it and at that party
that was where
you know he shot his wife and then shot
himself and that kind of
signaled the beginning of you know the
party's over now
kind of thing yeah it just porn went
from like
something kind of kind of like mimicking
hollywood it went from that
to becoming basically a machine
because that's what he got was no longer
really a director he was just a business
owner and they would just
use videotape which is real cheap and
you don't need big crews and you don't
even need porn stars you just use
hiring new talent all the time the
numbers of them expanded
you know there weren't many porn stars
in the 70s there was a [ __ ] coming up in
the 80s and the 90s
and they were only around a couple years
and they never gone they didn't make
much money
maybe it's some but not a whole lot and
it became a machine
not really a [ __ ] artistic yeah it
wasn't about quality anymore and you
know yeah you could argue that like
you know it was never about quality it's
just about like people getting off but
i think one of the points of this movie
and
the reason why the reason why burt
reynolds character jack horner was such
a sympathetic character was because yes
he was making porn
he thought it was art and yeah and yes
it was terrible like you see
this is a giant [ __ ] you know what i
mean it's just like all this kind of
like terrible acting yeah yeah
which is i love the way like when you're
a really good actor you can play a bad
actor in a movie you know what i mean
like really well but they did
that really well but i think like he
really had a dream
that he wanted to make a really good
porn movie
because he even says like during that
diner scene where it's like they're
sitting around that he gives a strategy
yeah saying it's like once you once
they've jerked off i want them just like
sit there stewing at it because they
can't leave because they want to see
what happens at that
just another era man remember there was
a
there was a [ __ ] funny cheech and
chong skit they [ __ ] go into the porn
theater together to sit down and [ __ ]
cheating cheech goes oh what's this oh
come let's go
your feet were [ __ ] sticking to the
ground well yeah very sticky those porn
things i understand how they could
[ __ ] go into that [ __ ] man
just [ __ ] are hardcore i mean
well don't yeah like just don't think
about all the diseases that you're
probably exposing yourself to just by
going into this place
i remember i grew up in daytona beach
and while when i was a kid
i remember there being a porn theater on
ridgewood avenue i never went in there
obviously because i was little
but i remember seeing the marketing yeah
they showed the
pussycat theater yeah long beach that
was near where i lived yeah
you could walk you could walk through
there from uh where i lived for a little
while uh when i was in military school i
can't remember the name of the [ __ ]
street that we lived
we had a little apartment there for a
while yeah that's before we went to
brazil
yeah i remember the thing is it's like
that was just like a normal thing it was
on it that was like downtown and like a
big part of the scene
big part of the uh the scenery of
california
yeah like porn well it's an iconic corn
films
signed and like [ __ ] like that because i
remember seeing like seeing it in movies
and [ __ ] like that
yeah yeah it was icon at the time
there's a big hotel across the street he
looked like a gigantic tall castle like
20 stories tall maybe
i don't know if that's still there
anymore i probably tore it down yeah it
was some kind of an office building i
think
um tila was saying this is one of
probably one of her top five favorite
movies ever
uh amanda was saying her favorite scene
was the one where roller girl kicks the
[ __ ] out of that uh
that dude on the ground like a limousine
i yeah i actually like that scene too
uh but yeah so so i really like how
everything is kind of idyllic at the
beginning because like i said that's
kind of what it was like in the 70s you
know there's
there were porn stars they were making
actual films uh you could make a [ __ ]
ton of money doing it
you know the yes that there was a stigma
about it but
you know they didn't really care it was
kind of like a a big party and like i
said it was almost kind of like an
extended family
oh hold on one second what's that tila i
was uh re-watching a mega man right now
i had to pause it that [ __ ] is sucking
that [ __ ] is so [ __ ] awesome
because i got it on blue i got it on dvd
and watching it now that's very relevant
to today
the family is basically antifa you'll
see it's like
it's exactly the same thing destroying
the past and
it's good it's good the bio warfare and
plague you'll see but yeah you need to
watch that one okay go ahead
uh i forgot i got what you're talking
about yeah yeah i did um
yeah so basically we talked about this
because we did a show about the
wonderland
murders and the scene in this which a
couple of people have brought up
uh already because you know the the drug
dealer scene
with alfred molina with the the night
ranger song and the
rick springfield song and everything
which is probably one of the best scenes
in this movie
uh is actually partially based on that
where like the the gang
you know after dirk digler and his two
buddies
are you know they've become drug addicts
they've lost most of their money
uh you know they got kind of kicked out
of jack horner's
studio because of their coke fueled
rages
and so they decide they're going to rob
this drug dealer and then they go there
and it's just i love the way that that
[ __ ] thing is shot
because it's just kind of like um you
know the music is really loud
alfred molina is being all like [ __ ]
happy
and singing along and everything and
then he's got that kid cosmo
that it's like throwing the firecrackers
it's like the three guys are like
sitting on the [ __ ] couch and they're
all like freaking out because they're
all nervous because they're trying to
scam
the dude and it's just like this really
really great like [ __ ] tense
scene but what oh nothing oh i thought
in the comments
he said that they watched it last night
at mega man they loved it so yeah okay
yeah if i can very relevant to what's
going on right now
i love watching us go man it's [ __ ]
awesome this movie's awesome
aged very well yeah yeah louis said
there was a pussycat theater by where
i lived all i remember it smelled awful
when i used to when i used to go buy it
yeah well yeah probably i'm sure
um imagine if your job to clean that
place up well i'm safe with somebody's
job
yeah that's got to be like low part of
the [ __ ] totem pole man
gross yeah but uh yeah it's just so
funny because i mean they got
one the soundtrack for this is fantastic
everybody in this is fantastic like i
said even though dirk diggler is kind of
like the focus
and you know a lot of the stuff that's
going on around him but
you know there's a lot of main
characters in this i mean can we talk
about like [ __ ]
don cheadle as uh you know as buck
like the guy that works in the stereo
store yeah that was my favorite one of
my favorite characters though
he's so good he was the most sympathetic
of all the characters yeah he was just a
really nice he was trying to make
something out of himself you know with
wanted his own store to uh you know
selling electronics and
he was mostly bullshitting about knowing
electronics but he had passion behind
elections and he gets [ __ ] over
but he does meet a good woman and he
hooks up with this blind chick she gets
pregnant and i thought he was going to
get killed in the end but he didn't he
he he he came up an opportunity
[ __ ] came up and he that's a great
thing
he took he took the money and [ __ ]
got the [ __ ] out of there i mean i love
the scene where he's
trying to sell that guy the stereo yeah
and he's like telling him all the stuff
and the guy
and the guy seems like he's kind of like
okay you know maybe and then he puts the
eight track in there and it's just going
and then he's like go ahead move if you
have to [ __ ] and the guy's like yeah bye
he [ __ ] the sail up and the guy the
guy who owned the store
what kind of brother are you country
western music
we'll be getting he was wearing country
clothes and [ __ ] because it's coming
back it's coming back no it's not coming
up he was
well the the cowboy i think is pretty
yeah the thing about it was that um
yeah because that other that other woman
that worked on the movie she's like you
know this look it's like five or six
years ago or whatever
like it was like from a long time ago
and he's like what if you can't tell me
about my look what about your look she's
like i have a look
then you read chocolate love yeah then
it really appears later on in the
[ __ ] rick james outfit like a
prototype
rick james from outer space and [ __ ] and
he's looking all bummed out like
it didn't work well i think the reason
that he's probably one of the most
sympathetic characters and everybody in
this is sympathetic
even if they even if they're fuck-ups
but he's the most sympathetic because
you can tell that he's like
a really good-hearted person and he's
trying to find an identity like he feels
like he doesn't fit in anywhere
and so he's trying to try to make a
neighbor carve out a place for himself
so i think it's like really cool at the
end i mean the one scene where
you know his pregnant wife is in the car
and he stops at the donut shop and like
goes in to get the donuts
and that's like such a great scene
because i mean even when he's just there
picking out the donuts and it's it's a
long scene like he's just there and he's
like oh is that are those for christmas
that's cute and it's like all this other
kind of stuff and then just like the
tension builds up and builds up
because you hadn't seen it in a long
time so you thought he was gonna kill
but that's not how it goes like it
yes the place does get robbed but
everybody else gets killed and then he
gets all the money and he's just kind of
like the money laying there
you know what i mean the business owner
was dead he wouldn't he didn't need the
money that's what i'm saying
he had a baby on the way yeah and he
wanted to open his own store and he got
to so he got his own
he got out of the bourne business and if
you notice too in that scene
like he's not wearing like a silly
costume in that one he just kind of
looks like a normal dude yeah
he's a normal guy he just became a
normal like he kind of like came into
his own identity which i thought was
really nice
because i feel like everybody got it as
dark as this movie goes
i mean it does go pretty dark it's still
funny but like in a blackly humorous
kind of way because like you know
people get [ __ ] shot and killed uh
you know and
all this terrible stuff happens but
pretty much everybody gets a little bit
of redemption at the end
except for the dude except for the
colonel who was a child pornographer so
[ __ ] him
yeah now if you um have not if you like
this movie
and you have not seen moat you are
[ __ ] up
moping because it explores very similar
in a way
but it it gets pretty dark but it's
still a cool movie
and it's based also based on something
that actually happened
based on two dudes who tried to become
porn legends and [ __ ] no they
that's not what happened to them but uh
c-mope m-o-p-e
yeah really good i mean you can tell
that it was really influenced by boogie
nights
but that's not a bad thing because i
mean that's not a bad thing it plays in
the 80s though
yeah it was a different era yeah i just
i feel like
the best thing about this i mean the
production design of this you really
feel like it's the [ __ ] 70s man i
mean they really did a good job with
like
i remember production design the
interiors of the houses the
the [ __ ] soundtrack is so awesome
that's the way california looked when i
was a kid
everything about this is good i love um
i just i love the opening scene where
they introduce
um because i was watching a video that
was kind of like analyzing
the opening scene which is only i think
it's only three minutes long
but it's that long tracking shot through
the nightclub and they introduce a lot
of the main characters
and they don't even have to have like a
lot of dialogue or anything like that
just the way they interact with one
another like just
tells the viewer like immediately what
the relationships between the people are
and it's just like really really well
done
you know growing up half the time in
long beach california in the 70s you
know i left in
i think an 81 is when i left maybe 82.
um the the newer houses and the newer
locations the interiors looked like in
this movie it all looked like something
out of a goddamn love hotel
it was [ __ ] tacky tacky as [ __ ]
but you didn't know it was tacky but it
just looked like a [ __ ] it looked
like a [ __ ] orgy was going to break
out at any [ __ ] minute you go to the
house party
you go into these houses had these huge
roofs the fireplace was damn in the
living room almost and just weird [ __ ]
and it was just like big old [ __ ]
huge furniture huge furniture everything
looked like you could have sex on it
[Laughter]
like the [ __ ] chairs were big enough
for [ __ ] three people to get in
them and sofas were giant [ __ ]
everything had looked like water beds
you had water beds and everything
and [ __ ] beans and [ __ ]
hanging down in between the doorways and
yeah
it looked like this what you see it in
this movie that's the way it should look
in the nice houses
[ __ ] it was tacky it was [ __ ]
tacky
but nobody nobody thought it was tacky
out there no at the time you thought the
ship was cool as [ __ ] it was like
something out of [ __ ] fantasy i under
the love boat or something you know i
mean that was like high-tech [ __ ] you
know i was like oh
this is [ __ ] great but you look at it
now you go yeah it looks like some
people give a [ __ ]
looks like something from porn flick
which maybe i mean
just the whole kind of vaguely sleazy
yes sleazy everything had like a sleazy
sex
to it like why the [ __ ] do you need
a [ __ ] couch that [ __ ] goes up
into the corner and then turns the
corner and comes out
and it's five feet [ __ ] thick and
it's always [ __ ] 17 inches off the
ground
you can [ __ ] sleep like nine people
on this [ __ ] thing and all the
carpets were shattered
[Music]
[Laughter]
lamps that touched the ceiling went all
the way down and you might have [ __ ]
a bunch of projectors on it and then
you'd have like a chandelier hanging and
it would be like a [ __ ]
inside the chandelier it would actually
be like a greek statue
with [ __ ] little fishing line that
went all around
and oil would drip down it it was just
the time i remember
those things just tacky but the thing
about some of
sites and [ __ ] colored lights on yeah
see but
i'm gonna say that like particularly in
this i love the
the interior design of um the
of jack horner's house like the party
house because a lot of [ __ ] takes place
in there
and you know i could do without like the
faux stone on the walls and stuff i know
that was all the rage like um among like
kind of upper middle class people back
then
but some of the like hanging lamps and
stuff i love
those colored bead like those colored
blue site like hanging like i love those
i would still have those in my house
nowadays um
so some of the [ __ ] from the 70s yeah is
super tacky
yeah it was like living in the banana
split exactly that's exactly what i
talked about
zach said i split zach said i think the
80s were uglier though
i would agree with you on that i didn't
like it went the opposite direction real
minimal simplistic [ __ ]
everything was niggles [ __ ] chrome
and glass
everything was chrome and glass and
square and beige
yeah yeah and gray pink
like a pale pink exactly yeah coral teal
looking [ __ ]
teal yeah it got it got it it had to try
to
triangular for that banana splits look
for [ __ ] you know
of the 70s it tried to go in the
opposite direction patrick nagle [ __ ]
prince everywhere
yeah i remember yeah i remember my best
friend in high school i had a had a
bunch of those on her wall
but um well because duran duran that was
the cover of rio patrick nagle did the
cover of rio but um yeah i mean if i had
to pick but of the aesthetic i would
definitely pick the 70s because the 80s
i mean certain subcultures in the 80s
obviously like i like the goth and death
rock thing but it's like the mainstream
[ __ ] from the 80s super ugly
i didn't like that real corporatist
beige minimalist kind of [ __ ]
about the 90s the 90s was more 80s you
can go back
and look at 90s stuff 90s but with
yeah it looked it looked 80 it's weird
because the 90s kind of went in a way
where it's like you kind of had one
faction going in like a grunge direction
um so kind of back into like punk rock
kind of hippie kind of [ __ ] and then the
other way they went like
ultra neon like almost a 60s throwback
like everything was like neon colors
those big like backwards pants remember
all that kind of [ __ ] yeah so there's
all that kind of stuff
yeah i don't i feel like the 90s
maybe i don't know maybe didn't have as
distinctive a style
yeah the 80s or the 70s it did but and
some
90s hair started to kind of look 70s and
80s again it was just it's just funny
poofy looking hair
it's weird you can go back and look on
youtube you can see old stuff from the
80s
go look at malls like any footage of
[ __ ] malls
that were taken in the 80s and the 90s
90s malls like from the vhs people had
vhs cameras it's still around you'll see
what people were wearing as they were
walking around in the malls and
it kind of vaguely still looked 80s to
me and i see it now
we didn't yeah looked 80s in in those
days but you look at it now there wasn't
enough difference
zach was like i can't even think of what
the 2000s were doing that's what i mean
i feel like
i feel like as um actually like the
2000s
well i feel like as subcultures have
become more uh
diffused um i feel like there's
not you don't have that iconic look from
a decade anymore
yeah really i mean there's trends but
[ __ ] man like
i even look every now and then because
you know like i said i you know i was
trained as a graphic designer so
every now and then i'll be like what are
the design trends for this year
and there's always kind of like 10 of
them yeah it's never just like one thing
mid to late 90s the the girls fashions
looked great i thought
they had some good [ __ ] during i just
like that look
even even some of the raver type clothes
like
jinkos and [ __ ] some of these girls are
wearing jinko pants [ __ ]
belly shirts and [ __ ] piercings in
their [ __ ] bellies and weird [ __ ]
that
i thought it looked good yeah but then
they had 90s goth clothes
like what you would see in ginger snaps
that looked good
once they became yeah i liked that one
once they became werewolves and [ __ ]
yeah
so it looked good there was some 90 [ __ ]
like i said more a subcultural
yeah the cultures knew what they were
doing not the mainstream the mainstream
kind of
i mean when i think of 90s mainstream
fashion i think of like vanilla ice
yeah you know what i'm like [ __ ] like
that where everything had like neon
colored squiggles and [ __ ] like that on
it look at what strawberry switchblade
was or excuse me switchblade symphony
look at what switchblade symphony was
wearing and just google images and
that was 90s kind of goth slash trip hop
kind of
i like that yeah look good but yeah so i
i mean one of the things i don't know i
just i love
the clothes in boogie nights are good
because
they evoke the 70s but they don't like
draw a lot of attention to themselves
because i i feel like sometimes movies
that are set in the 70s
you know sometimes the costume design
will be just like a little bit too much
and you know because people like look
how 70s the clothes are
yeah like it's a costume like it's a
costume i feel like the they really did
a good job of like the clothes just
being like obviously 70s but
naturalistic and it was more like i mean
there's one scene early on
like in the in the disco with john c
reilly's character
reed and he the shirt that he's wearing
my dad had that exact same shirt back in
the 70s so it's just kind of like
and i think the ugly ones the ugly silk
ones that they bought
because remember reed and uh and dirk
bought the same
shirt and then scottie played by uh
philip seymour hoffman he bought the
same one too because he was trying to be
as cool as them
and so they all three had that same ugly
silk shirt on i think my dad had one
like that too
another good thing another good uh part
of this movie is when they were when
dirk digler's trying to record all that
music and everything that they're
[ __ ] singing is like
they go yeah that's what bad 80s [ __ ]
do you know what song that what it was
bugging me because i was like i know
i've heard the song
1984 no it was what was it the song they
were singing and the thing
that was the song from the [ __ ]
animated transformers movie from the 80s
you got the touch
[Laughter]
i didn't really well because i saw the
movie again because i've seen it a few
times
um and i saw it again last night and i
was like i know i know that song from
somewhere else and these
that's where it's from it's just metal
lyrics some of them were good you know
like iron maiden judas priest they were
the masters of [ __ ] 80s metal lyrics
but most 80s metal sucked because
the guys that wrote that [ __ ] could not
grasp
they could not grasp anything that was
abstract they had to spell out
everything that they were [ __ ] yeah
everything was just so on the nose yeah
it's just like this not artistic at all
you know he's telling the [ __ ] story
and she wakes up in the morning
and she puts on her shoes then he gets
in her mustang
what the [ __ ] you talking then she
drives over to her friend's house
you know it's just like [ __ ] dude
what are you telling yeah it's terrible
but her daddy keeps on hitting her
it's very literal yeah literal [ __ ]
nothing everything was very literal that
was why when [ __ ] skinny puppy hit
the [ __ ] scene and bauhaus and [ __ ]
they was all real abstract the [ __ ] he
talking about
white on white translucent black capes
back on the rack
the virginal brides file passage tuned
well i mean they are talking about
something literal but they're they're
saying it like
yeah they're just in the poem yeah
and some of the some of their lyrics um
were very abstract
in a sense that they could mean lots of
different things well uh skinny puppy
lyrics i heard that was just it was a
couple of paragraphs that they would cut
the sentences out
yeah part and then cut words out of the
sentences and then take that and throw
it in a hat and kind of pull it back out
and randomly
yeah put those phrases in something that
was like
like those poems right yeah yeah that's
how that's how they read those lyrics
and it was very expressive if you guys
never heard skinny puppy check out old
skinny puppy
like bites and remission that's a that's
a good album
yeah well or uh what was the other one
mind the perpetual intercourse that was
a good i like that one
mega said did tom write lyrics for
motley crew yeah
especially later on the first couple
albums the lyrics weren't that bad but
they just kept getting worse
yeah it's like you know i i don't mean
to like cast ass versions because
sometimes
you know simple lyrics are fine like i
said i like a lot of old like rockabilly
and stuff like that which those
you know those lyrics are just very
simple and very straightforward
you know look at somebody like the
ramones or somebody like that which is
like simple straightforward
there's nothing wrong with that but it's
just kind of like i do
feel like i think that that got its
worst
um you know it kind of came to its worst
thing like during the 80s metal phase
like you said because
they couldn't just be like oh let's do a
simple baby i love you type song no
they had to like take it to an excess
but make it even more literal and that
made it like lamer
yeah they had to be teaching you
something about history or they had to
be i could talk about something to
happen
in the skies above london or some [ __ ]
like that
during the [ __ ] you know what i mean
no we're gonna take it back to the honky
motherland the time during the time that
[ __ ] napoleon was [ __ ] marching
against the russians and just
it just you know it was all this literal
stuff
you know each song was about something
and it wasn't personal it was something
like historical yeah or they're
iron maiden basically made four or five
albums talking about books that steve
harris read
yeah now every one of them was about a
book he read or a movie he saw
kind of like the misfits you got a song
about conan every single misfit song was
about a horror movie
[Laughter]
and he's just describing what happened
in the movie read a book red dune gonna
write a song about doom
that's a great song though i like the
peace of mind album i mean the thing
about it though is that you can make
lyrics that are because i think that's
why
writing lyrics and writing poetry and
stuff like that is so hard
is because you want to talk about
something specific
um something relatable but you have to
make it vague or broad enough that
everybody can
cast their own kind of thing into it and
oh i get what you're talking about or
this is what i think they're talking
about
you have to make it universal but also
specific which is really difficult
to do in such a limited time frame what
what the best of
metal lyrics were the 70s that was 70s
judas priest
and [ __ ] very late 70s early 80s iron
maiden the first two albums iron maiden
and killers
they have the paul diano you paul diana
paul diana was really
the best vocal best vocalist for iron
maiden oh even though i love
um bruce dickinson you know he had a lot
of good albums i liked i liked both of
them but
paul just it was a very hot and dirty
kind of punk rock
metal sound i just liked it and it was
just visceral it didn't really have
it was like i said it was an app it was
more abstract and artistic it wasn't
about
it wasn't about aces high and [ __ ]
fighter planes over the [ __ ] you know
battle britain and it wasn't about all
that historical [ __ ] it was just about
dudes killing chicks because he's a
[ __ ] weirdo
[Laughter]
or i'm a ghost now and i'm watching you
you know
yeah yeah yes yes they made a song
called the twilight zone
and a dude died and he's watching his
girlfriend and he's [ __ ] missing her
and he's thinking i think i'm going to
do something to you so you can join me
on the other side
imagine that but it's very vague well
see that's like
that's a story that anybody could relate
to he's not really
referring he yes he's referring to a
specific situation
but he's not referring to like a
specific